hey today we're gonna play pray to the
gods you better pray to the gods this
game is good
it's a spiritual successor to Shadow of
the Colossus which is one of the finest
piece of game you can find I'm sick by
the way so in case I sound like I'm
trying to keep a sexy voice or some [ __ ]
I'm not alright got an arrow
you made that [ __ ] now we have the bow
and the arrow which oh hey let's
practice
okay let's hit the one in the middle
okay my mouth was sensitive hey you were
supposed to shoot right and release No
okay releasing ah I could potentially be
the worst player at this game because
I'm probably the only one that isn't a
developer that played this game but a
bit a bit bit a bit a bit a bit but a
bit better beep a bit a bit but I think
what would really struck them it struck
me with the shadow vocalizes is how
[ __ ] impressive it is it like it's a
PlayStation 2 game and it runs like what
it what it can do is a lot it's but it's
good it's good that's good what I'm
trying to say thank you
alright I'm just gonna keep rolling are
you
oh my god oh my god I [ __ ] myself bring
it bring it may bring [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I
think I got a rock no need nuts right
they're scary they're [ __ ] scary okay
holy [ __ ] this is so immersive I've been
playing for just a couple minutes but
I'm well into this this is really cool I
am honestly not trying to oversell this
because I got to play it earlier and you
can't play it
look it says pre Alma zero point one
points if that means it's early well I
think a storm is coming this is
practically what it's like to live in
Brighton I like how it borrows from shot
of a colossus but it's still very much
its own thing can I make a snow angel
obviously I am going to make a penis you
can make a penis in the game ten out of
ten dude that is so creepy the whispers
is done really well this is actually
creeping me out
in daylight you know what I mean you
know what I mean don't tell me you're
not [ __ ] yourself right now as well
okay I got him got him got him got him
got him I didn't even flinch I didn't
know I was playing a [ __ ] horror game
dude
miss me [ __ ] oh dude actual goosebumps
that is so intense I love it it's that
[ __ ] bacon oh cool
of course there's climbing that's cool
that's a big thing in there the other
game that I mentioned about a million
times
oh I didn't see this before oh they're
not bacon they're fire way wait I can
sleep
the very first okay I bet everyone so it
plays more on the survival part I think
that's cool okay what do we have there
it is the grappling that's awesome I got
a [ __ ] grappling here how does it
work green oh yeah want to go down now
I'm scared and [ __ ] this rock right
now this rock is my [ __ ] [ __ ] man
got the grappling hook now let's head to
the boss oh oh it's happening it's
happening it's gonna come from the sky
I'm sure of it Oh
oh never mind it came from the [ __ ]
rocks Jesus look at those man boots
where we gonna shoot in the sensitive
area
now the other sensitive area in between
the butt cheeks got him
hey-oh and we are on oh this takes me
back man 8 don't just walk you crazy we
got to go to the Ted don't mind me I'm
just literally like a parasite on your
body oh I got a hold on my clicking hold
on girl
hold on child we're on we're on holy
[ __ ] it did it okay what happens now
whoa this is unexpected
oh okay okay since it's a demo I'm
guessing they're taking it away from us
damn that was a lot better than I
expected that's really cool I still had
pretty high expectations all right hope
you enjoyed this gameplay if you did
leave a like I appreciate it thank you
so much for watching and as always stay
awesome brush Michael give my channel to
Edgar
it's not worth it stuff worth living
he's not even wearing [ __ ] gloves
he's not even wearing gloves